how important do you think it is to
genuinely enjoy the side hustle you're
doing versus treat it more like
instrumental for the sake of building
some amount of Financial Freedom further
down the line I think there has to be a
level of intrinsic motivation from from
joy that you get from it the reason I
say that is just because there's two
sides to this right there's like
intensity and there's consistency I
think that money can create intensity
like I think that you can see like oh
I'm gonna make a million dollars this
year and it's going to make me focus a
ton and I'm gonna really grind it out
and you know put in all these hours and
do this I'm going to get the bonus or
I'm going to make my YouTube channel big
whatever but the consistency and your
ability to show up every single day when
you feel good when you don't feel good
when you're tired when it's a holiday
when your family has something and you
have to miss it like that consistency
only comes from enjoying it and from
wanting to be a part of it and enjoying
the process around it and enjoying the
ups and downs like it's not always going
to be good you're going to put things
out you're proud of and they're not
going to go anywhere you're going to get
punched in the face haters are going to
tell you they want you to go burn in a
house you know like all that stuff the
consistency only comes from enjoying it
along the way and like I you know I I
will say this until the cows come home
the biggest driver of My Success in
anything in life has always been that I
am consistent baseball I was never the
most talented never going to be the most
talented but I was just gonna show up
every single day and just come at you
over and over and over again and it's
really hard to beat someone that does
that like it's just very hard to durably
beat someone that just keeps getting up
keeps showing up and I felt that way
when I took you know my approach to
Twitter I was like I might not write the
most viral post ever I've still never
had a post that goes over I mean now I
just had my biggest one ever but never
had something go over a hundred thousand
likes I see people putting out like 10
Excel tips and it goes over 100 000
likes and it's crazy to me like I've
never done that but I have written
something on Twitter every single week
you know since May of 2020 and I would
stack that consistency up against anyone
in the world that has you know been
around during that period And so people
are like oh what's the hack you know how
did you grow to this big I'm like well
the hack is that I wrote 250 000 words
on Twitter or over the course of the
last two years like that's the hack I
spent you know thousands of hours
writing on the weekends you know while
people were out doing fun stuff like I
just I enjoyed it and I got energy out
of it and so I wanted to keep doing it
and I think you have to enjoy it in
order to do that because otherwise I
would have just been miserable I would
have been at home writing you know
working long hours because I was trying
to balance it against my day job until I
ended up doubling down on this and the
enjoyment is so key to creating that
consistency hey friends thank you so
much for watching if you enjoyed this
clip then click here for the full
unedited episode and if you like that
then do please consider subscribing to
the channel it means a lot thank you so
much and have a great day bye